foreign
Fort Lauderdale Florida hi Pat welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
okay thanks for having me and your staff
answer my email so I was calling in
reference to
um I have I did the Financial Peace
University during covet I paid off a
rental home all my Cadet credit card
debt and my my car my only debt right
now is my um I'm sorry my only BET right
now is my my home that I currently live
in and my student loans so I have a
financial advisor that I reached out to
and I told him that I wanted to pay it's
only I only owe them down to fifteen
thousand dollars on the student loans so
I told them I wanted to pay that off in
the next year and he feels that I should
not do that instead allocate that money
towards my Roth uh Ira so my question is
do I go against him do I go you know I
don't know which road to take
and how much do you owe on your student
loan
fifteen thousand so I'm almost there
okay but I'm about to be 60 next month
and I still have a student on and I
don't want and next weekend I don't want
to have this over my head anymore
well you know what you need to do and
that's pay off those loans you have the
money to do it
well my goal was to pay them off and pay
aggressively and get them done in one
year the fifteen thousand okay well
here's the thing it's kind of like going
to a dentist and saying hey do I have
any cavities that you think would need
to be filled the dentist is going to
find some cavities you know what I mean
and so the financial advisor wants you
to invest because that's how they make
money and they're not thinking about the
full picture in this case about your
freedom and your retirement and your
goals and your peace
okay
and I know that this loan forgiveness
isn't going nowhere so that's why I said
I had it and I just want to get this
done with so here's the thing
okay is his theory if I understand it
correctly
is that instead of paying off the 15 000
you should put the fifteen thousand into
his
Investments correct correct yeah and so
what he's saying is is that the student
loan he can make more on the money than
the student loan interest is does that
sound right
yes yeah okay so what if he came to you
and said uh what's the interest rate on
your student loan by the way Pat 4.25
okay what if he said I've arranged a
million dollar loan for you
at 4.25 I want you to borrow a million
dollars
and give it to me to invest because I
can make more than 4.25 on it
what would you do what would you do
what would I do
um
I don't know I don't I'm not really sure
what to do would you borrow it's not a
trick question would you go borrow a
million dollars no at 4.25 so that you
could invest the money with him because
he says he can make more than that
it's not a trick question I'm not trying
to catch you off guard but what I am
doing is just sometimes when you're
looking at a decision like this if you
add a bunch of zeros to the decision
it makes the principal become very
crystal clear
so let me tell you what just happened in
our conversation
okay when I made it not fifteen thousand
but I made it a million you felt the
weight of debt
you felt the risk of debt and you said I
might actually intellectually know that
I might make more than four percent but
I'm not willing to take the risk
that I won't I don't like the weight of
that that's what just happened in this
conversation wasn't it that's what your
brain did
am I wrong
no I got yes you're right okay and so
because it's only fifteen thousand it
makes you go well maybe he's right
but your heart is saying no no no no no
I want the peace
okay so I would agree with you I I think
he's wrong and I would pay off my
student loans and I also would consider
a different financial advisor because
he's not aligned with your value system
and how you see things
and his job is not to change your values
his job is to make suggestions you know
did you hear what you said you said do I
go against him
this is your money
yeah you shouldn't be asking a question
about do I go against him he's not your
husband
is a financial advisor
it should be going you know I don't
understand why he would say that I don't
want to do that and it makes me confused
that that's the way but you know but but
instead you're having to go but so what
else is he bringing to you that you
didn't catch
that's what bothers me and I'm not
saying he's a crook I'm saying he
doesn't agree with your way of seeing
the world and you should have someone
that says I agree with your way of
seeing the world that's why we tell
people you know Financial smartvester
Pros they are aligned with our way of
seeing the world they're not going to
tell you to go into debt to invest and
if you say I want to pay off this debt
they're not going to go whoa hold on we
shouldn't do that you should go invest
in matter of fact they would say yeah
you should do that before you talk to me
and say come back in six months when
you're debt free exactly exactly and
I'll help you with your Roth IRA then
and I'll and you're a little bit behind
because you're 60 years old so we need
to get going they'll encourage you right
and that kind of stuff but they're not
going to put you in debt or keep you in
debt in order for to align in order to
do investing and you know that guy could
be doing that with nefarious motives he
could be just because he wants a
commission but it could be he just
really believes it's the right thing and
he's wrong
that's very much possible and I'm I'm
more scared of an enthusiastic ignoramus
than I am a con artist they can do some
danger yeah because I because they're
enthusiastic you know and um so yeah I I
think you need to rethink who you're
taking advice from because it doesn't
align with your values
not because it doesn't align with mine
but because it doesn't line with yours
that's what's important and and so
you know I have CPA one time years ago
George we had when Ramsey was a small
company it was a is actually a friend
and um but uh he knew I had gone through
everything losing everything you know
but you know I'm now debt free and I
don't borrow money anymore he came in
he's kind of
he was kind of going to tell me how
things are kind of going to school me up
a little bit you know and you know well
you know I don't agree with you about
this whole debt thing and being debt
free and all that but we don't have to
be in agreement about that for me to do
your taxes oh boy or to be your CPA and
I thought yeah actually we do kind of do
you know we kind of a deal breaker
because a CPA who can't do math is
bothersome
you know that's just a problem so I
can't I can't do that no it's not you
know we cannot be we can be friends we
can hang out on the weekend you're not
doing my books
there's a big difference it's a
different thing here so yeah I mean I
got lots of friends who think I'm nutty
and I think they are but that's okay and
some are closer friends than others but
man yeah you know it's you know you're
not going to do that we have to be
aligned on this it's very important
folks that when you're dealing in the
financial realm that you get someone
with a heart of a teacher that's huge
and someone that actually explains to
you and doesn't just tell you oh good go
do this because I said so they should be
slow methodical and go here's exactly
why they're making suggestions and then
you are still making the choice
that's a huge part of this don't ever
call the show and said the financial
advisor made me no you call the shots
you make the choices my guy lost all my
money nope
nope
you did
because you didn't make the decision
it's your it's your responsibility to
decide
this is the problem like when I'm
meeting with the guys in the NFL or
something they go I got me a guy I got
me a guy I'm like no no no dude you're
the guy
you're the guy that's a dangerous
sentence I got me a guy is what you say
right before all your money disappears
yeah
no that guy's got used what's happening
no you you have to make your own
decisions that your financial your
mortgage person your insurance person
your estate planning attorney your uh
your investment advisor for sure are
teachers they give you ideas and advice
and then you
decide
period that's the only way